[Musik]
bei blaulicht und martinshorn der punkt
viele menschen an einem tag
wenn aber die sirenen heulen dann steigt
die aufmerksamkeit etwas ernsthaftes
scheint passiert zu sein
dabei ist vieles denkbar ein chemie
unfall ein cyberangriff oder gar der
totalen blackout alle szenarien machen
irgendwie angst aber ist diese angst
berechtigt wie gut ist deutschland auf
ein katastrophenfall vorbereitet und
damit herzlich willkommen zu unserem
themenschwerpunkt während der korona
pandemie die die ganze welt aus den
angeln hoch waren wir nicht gut
vorbereitet
seit wochen befinden sie sich im
krisenmodus in dieser pandemie wie
angekündigt war und in der doch alles
improvisiert werden musste
treffen bei der brk sondereinsatzgruppe
in cham
das ist schlimm gewesen war es im märz
abgespielt hatte ich selber ich weiß wie
viele adressen man versucht hat zu
bekommen und jeder ist losgerannt um
irgendetwas zu beschaffen
wir hätten uns alle nicht vorgestellt
dass das so kurz und so schnell so
schwierig wird weil die vorbereitungen
für solche einsatzlagen liegen ja bei
uns beim fachdienst wir sind darauf
vorbereitet aber nicht in diesen
ausmaßen
ende januar hatte bayern bekanntlich
deutschlands erster kugelt patienten
gemeldet
vier wochen später befand sich das land
hektisch auf einkaufstour krankenhäuser
pflegeheime rettungsdienste riefen acht
desinfektionsmitteln masken
schutzausrüstung überall fehlten sie
versorgungslücken die nie wieder
passieren dürfen fordert das brk
wichtig ist dass wir schnell wieder dazu
kommen dass der staat selber bevorratung
gemacht dass er wieder diese zentren
geschaffen werden die schon einmal da
waren im sogenannten kalten krieg damals
hielt es das land mit den vorbereitungen
auf den katastrophenfall noch anders die
alte bundesrepublik hatte angst vor dem
ultimativen krieg und war deshalb stets
für den ernstfall bereit erinnerte
sicherheitsforscher carlo masala
wir hatten bis 1990 unter dem szenario
dass sie einen nuklearkrieg ausbricht
hoffen wir medikamenten bevorratung
lebensmittel bevorratung mundschutz
bevorratung ist alles mögliche was wir
alles 1990 abgebaut haben
da ist ja bei dieser krone pandemie die
wir gerade haben vor allen dingen darum
geht sozusagen wie man immer sagt die
kurve flach zu halten damit die
gesundheitssysteme nicht kollabieren
hätte ein katastrophenschutz sowie wir
ihnen von noch vor 1990 gehabt haben
zumindest dazu beigetragen dass wir
vielleicht auch eine andere politik
hätten fahren können weil wir nie vor
dem kollaps der gesundheitssysteme so
schnell gestanden rocks optisch braucht
zahlen schnitt durch sowas tauchen
wieder auf und genau das gegenteil hat
sich eben jetzt herausgestellt
überall im land waren notebook not
krankenhäuser und unzählige material
lebensmitteln und medikamenten lager
verteilt in denen bereitgehalten wurde
was für den notfall medizin bis der
eiserne vorhang fiel in roding etwa
blieb vom not krankenhaus nur noch das
lager das ist aufgelöst worden als
klassisches höchst krankenhauses nicht
mehr betriebsbereit also man könnte es
nicht mehr als klinik beziehen aber als
lagermöglichkeit für den
katastrophenschutz bietet es einfach
viel fläche
wir haben das bei hochwasserlagen für
die flüchtlinge gebraucht dort waren die
betten und das material überall im
einsatz
der landkreis hatte sich damals schlicht
gegen den abbau der feldbetten gewährt
im übrigen wurde der zivil- und
katastrophenschutz zurückgefahren
obgleich sich die risiken im grunde nur
änderten
der elfte september kam und das thema
bio terrorismus tauchte auf etwa 2001
als man in den usa antrags briefe mit
tödlichen milzbrand spuren entdeckt fünf
menschen starben
sechs jahre zuvor hatte ein
giftgasanschlag japan traumatisiert mit
13 toten und 6000 verletzten
trotz des großflächigen abbaus stellten
sich die
katastrophenschutzorganisationen so gut
es ging auf die neuen risiken ein und
mussten trotzdem mit ihren standard
vorräten als corona kam zunächst
improvisieren
obwohl es risikoanalysen obwohl es
pandemiepläne gab
bevorratung so die erfahrung hier löst
erhebliche kosten aus und nachträglich
oft kritik tritt vor ablauf des
verfallsdatums der ernstfall gar nicht
ein
wie im fall der schweinegrippe für die
deutschlandweit für knapp 600 millionen
euro impfstoff masken und grippemitteln
eingelagert und jahre später ungenutzt
vernichtet wurden
warum aber konnte in deutschland trotz
der reichlich mangelhaften vorbereitung
eine katastrophe verhindert werden
eine antwort findet sich im klinikum
weiden als die ersten koma patienten
eingeliefert wurden hat man einfach
richtig reagiert und clever improvisiert
in abstimmung mit den ad hoc
einberufenen krisenstäben errichtete man
zusammen mit den hilfsorganisationen
innerhalb von nur zwei tagen eine zelt
notaufnahme um mögliche corona fälle
sofort zu reparieren
voraussetzung dafür war die offizielle
ausrufung des katastrophenfalls der das
schnelle unorthodoxe handeln überhaupt
erst ermöglichte die ausstattung mit
schutz materialien hingegen war den
kliniken selbst überlassen ab corona
reichten die üblichen drei wochen
vorräte nur für wenige tage
wir sind an die politik gegangen wir
sind an vier mann gegangen die kontakte
hatten können sie uns bitte unterstützen
im hintergrund war dass unser aufwand
und viel arbeit es mir leisten mussten
damit wir die verschiedenen masken
bekommen dann kommt man zum beispiel nur
große menge in zehn bis fünfzehn 20.000
abnehmen wie die lagerkapazitäten hier
bei uns am klinikum nicht ausgereicht
haben wir haben gesagt wir nehmen die
mengen trotzdem also wir haben deutlich
höhere bestände und wollte es auch so
weiter halten erstmal bis jahresende
denn die kosten für mehr lagerhaltung
sind in den krankenhaus budgets nicht
vorgesehen wie es im fall einer zweiten
welle weitergeht ist bis jetzt nirgends
geregelt wir sprechen jetzt quasi mit
einem doppel experten herr professor
schrott sie sind geograf und sie sind
auch mitglied im deutschen komitee für
katastrophenvorsorge komitee das klingt
schon so nach geballter kompetenz
warum hat es bei der pandemie nicht so
gut mit der vorsorge geklappt wir haben
zwar aus der geschichte schon gelernt
wir hatten ja eine schwere
influenza-pandemie in den jahren 1918
bis 20 und daraus sind sicherlich auch
einige erkenntnisse sozusagen in die
gegenwart rüber gerettet worden
aber dieses ausmaß und auch die
geschwindigkeit hat glaube ich doch
viele überrascht so dass auch unsere
modernen lebens und wirtschaftswelt mit
einer völlig anderen kritischen
infrastruktur
doch unser gesamtes leben auf den kopf
gestellt hat also haben die mitglieder
in diesem vorsorge katastrophenvorsorge
komitee das gar nicht im blick gehabt es
ist so gefährlich werden könnte
das würde ich so nicht sagen also unser
ziel ist es in dem deutschen komitee für
katastrophenvorsorge ein netzwerk zu
bilden zu beraten und wissenstransfer zu
ermöglichen
unsere aufgabe ist es nicht ein
frühwarnsystem für alle möglichen
gefahren die wir uns denken können zu
implementieren und umzusetzen
wir sind ein beratendes organ wie ich
sagte ein netzwerk von experten
versuchen auch experten miteinander ins
gespräch zu bringen und eben wissen in
die breite bevölkerung zu transportieren
beispielsweise mit houston newslettern
aber auch mit gegenwärtig beispielsweise
bieten wir zu diesem aktuellen thema
webinar sun
das bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe ist mitglied im
komitee der katastrophenvorsorge und was
hinter diesem amt
das schauen wir uns jetzt an
katastrophenschutz ist in deutschland
ländersache
die koordinierung auf bundesebene ist
eine der aufgaben dieser behörde in bonn
des bundesamts für bevölkerungsschutz
und katastrophenhilfe dem
innenministerium unterstellt entwickeln
hier rund 300 bedienstete unter anderem
risikoanalysen für gefahrensituationen
aber auch konzepte und maßnahmen etwa
für stromausfälle hochwasser und andere
naturkatastrophen und sie informieren
und warnen die bevölkerung unter anderem
mit hilfe von nina das steht für notfall
informations und nachrichten app eine
art moderne warm sirene entwickelt 2015
aktuell immerhin knapp sieben millionen
nutzer mit informationen jetzt vor allem
zu corona der spiegel titelte kürzlich
das vergessene und ist diese kritik
berechtigt aus meiner sicht ist sie
nicht berechtigt und auch der duktus
dieses artikels wenn einige der unserer
zuhörerinnen und zuhörer ihn gelesen
haben trifft nicht wirklich den kern der
sache
dieses amt leistet gerade in bezug auf
vorsorge katastrophenvorsorge
beachtliches und ist in verschiedenen
feldern tätig um die bevölkerung
aufzuklären und auch zu warnen
die konstellation mit dem föderalen
system und den ministerien ist
sicherlich eine grauzone in die man ein
bisschen besser ein blick haben muss um
diese vorgänge verstehen zu koennen sie
leiten ein studiengang ein
masterstudiengang an der bonner uni so
katastrophenvorsorge und
katastrophenmanagement
das kann man bei ihnen lernen wir haben
tatsächlich studierende aus allen
möglichen wissenschaftsdisziplin das
sind frauen und männer die aus ihren
berufen herauskommen sie sind schon fach
und führungskräfte vielfach sie kommen
aus der medizin aus den
verwaltungswissenschaften aus den
ingenieurwissenschaften aus den
einschlägigen ich sag mal blaulicht
fraktionen
sie eben fachspezifisch ausgebildet sind
aber unsere modernen lebens und
wirtschafts welten haben gezeigt dass
die gefahren nicht sektoral zu bekämpfen
sind und wir verfolgen einen
holistischen das heißt einen
ganzheitlichen ansatz
sektorenübergreifend interdisziplinär
und genau das braucht die führungskraft
im modernen katastrophenmanagement
deswegen haben wir beispielsweise
landräte bei uns als studierende weil
sie merken dass mehr und mehr den
kommunen verantwortungen zu gespielt
wird und das erleben wir gegenwärtig in
der pandemie in der kobe 19 krise das
den kommunen kompetenzen zugesprochen
werden aber vielfach das wissen auch
fehlt die kommunen sind wichtig weil
katastrophenschutz ist nämlich
ländersache
und immer wenn es zu engpässen kommt
können sie natürlich beim bund am ziel
für anfordern und das ist auch fest
verankert im grundgesetz artikel 35 in
der korona krise haben die thw männer in
der logistik ausgeholfen
das team 1 osnabrück das team 2 fährt in
den süden von niedersachsen 45.000 ffp
masken 93.000 einmalhandschuhe und 1500
schutzanzüge werden heute in
niedersachsen verteilt not bedarf damit
die pflegeheime und krankenhäuser
wenigstens über die nächsten drei bis
fünf tage kommen beladen werden die
äcker wie morgens an einem geheimen
zentrallager des landes zu groß die
angst dass der geringe vorrat auch noch
geklaut wird
im logistikzentrum des
katastrophenschutzes werden die
lieferungen koordiniert doch jeder
antragsteller bekommt momentan nur einen
teil seiner bestellung damit nicht einer
leer ausgeht weil wir an einem tag das
gesamte material ausgegeben haben müssen
wir das entsprechend in kleinen chargen
rausgeben und dafür eben mehr
fachbehörden anfahren sobald sich die
material situation ein bisschen
entspannt werden wir natürlich auch die
erfüllung squaw deutlich steigern können
und mehr material in die fläche
ausliefern
ein bis zwei frachtmaschinen aus der
ganzen welt kommen pro woche in
niedersachsen an ein verlässlicher
vorrat lässt sich für die und planbare
corona pandemie damit aber nicht
aufbauen
wer genau also jeden tag die
schutzausrüstung aus dem landes vorrat
bekommt das entscheidet der krisenstab
nach dringlichkeit zweimal am tag muss
hier in der zentrale bewertet werden
den krankenhäuser und
pflegeeinrichtungen kommen momentan je
nach stärke des corona ausbruchs schnell
an ihre grenzen
heute meldet ein krankenhaus gar nur
noch für zwei tage genug schutzkleidung
für die mitarbeitenden zu haben
jetzt läuft der versuch heute abend noch
material ausliefern zu können
auch bei der stadt braunschweig ist die
lagerhalle der die lieferung des landes
sehnlichst erwartet und die anträge auf
mehr laufen schon
diese ffp masken gehen heute an den
pflegeheim und könnten wenigstens dort
die situation für ein paar tage
entspannen in der hoffnung möglichst
bald wieder auf der prioritätenliste
weit oben zu stehen wenn es wirklich
schlimm wird könnt ihr die bundeswehr
auch aushelfen
entschieden wird es hier im
bundesministerium der verteidigung die
soldaten haben schon ausgeholfen
beim elbhochwasser in der
flüchtlingskrise und auch anfangs bei
der korona krise fresspakete von der
bundeswehr autobahn a4 deutsch polnische
grenze soldaten versorgung trucker im
stau mit nahrungsmitteln die truppe
unterstützt dort wo zivile kräfte
engpässe haben wenn länder und gemeinden
die wirtschaft die polizei das
technische hilfswerk und alle weiteren
institutionen an die grenzen kommen dann
werden wir selbstverständlich auch
helfen
ganz vorn dabei der sanitätsdienst der
truppe die selbst sieben bundeswehr
krankenhäuser betreibt verteilt über die
republik wie in allen kliniken sollen
auch hier die intensiv kapazitäten
verdoppelt werden im kampf gegen korona
mehr als 2300 reservisten haben sich
mittlerweile freiwillig per hotline
gemeldet um die reguläre truppe dabei zu
unterstützen mehr als 900 von ihnen sind
bereits im einsatz
zustimmung für diese art bundeswehr
einsatz in zeiten von corona kommt auch
von der opposition darüber hinaus gehen
aber sollte es nicht ich finds
angesichts der tiefe der krise völlig
richtig dass alle verfügbaren kräfte
mobilisiert werden sowohl für logistik
als auch für unterstützung der
krankenhäuser
ich bedanke mich bei allen menschen
mitarbeiten und mithelfen wir brauchen
die bundeswehr gegebenenfalls einer
notlage für logistische unterstützung
auch die sanität kann wichtige beiträge
leisten wenn das gesundheitssystem
überfordert sein sollte aber die
bundeswehr es nicht ausgebildet für
polizeiaufgaben die bundeswehr leiste
lediglich als hilfe bei logistik
beschaffung versorgung als hilfe beim
bund ist also grundsätzlich möglich aber
ansonsten müssen im katastrophenfall die
städte selbst zurecht kommt so auch die
millionenstadt köln und damit er nichts
schief geht gibt es beispielsweise in
nordrhein-westfalen regelmäßig einen
sogenannten waren tag dann wird der
ernstfall durchgespielt
das ist nur ein probealarm deshalb nimmt
bastian blum die treppe zu seinem keller
auch ganz gemächlich im ernstfall wäre
der krefelder aber vorbereitet denn er
ist präsent man menschen die sich für
alle möglichen katastrophenfälle wappnen
in bluhms kleinen kellerraum lagern
vorräte für sechs wochen so lange könnte
er sich selbst seine frau und sein kind
versorgen ohne das haus zu verlassen
[Musik]
blum ist chef der treffer gemeinschaft
deutschland alles in diesem keller ist
penibel geplant seit zehn jahren tüftelt
er daran 90 liter wasser hat blumen auf
vorrat
und wenn es losgeht könnte er noch
kanister mit bis zu 150 litern befüllen
blum will auf jedes szenario optimal
vorbereitet sein
normale atemschutzmasken reichen will
nicht sicherer fühlt er sich mit solchen
gasmasken die das komplette gesicht
umschließen die sachen habe ich deshalb
angeschafft weil wir chemie
verarbeitende industrie hier haben in
greven und in den letzten acht jahren
schon einige große katastrophen in
diesen chemiepark passiert sind die
szenarien auf die sich trepper
vorbereiten möchte man sich eigentlich
lieber nicht vorstellen ein schwerer
chemieunfall eine naturkatastrophe oder
auch ein angriff auf sensible
infrastrukturen wie das stromnetz der
energieversorger energie in essen energy
betreibt strom wasser und gasnetze
neuerdings gibt es hier die cyber range
eine abteilung spezialisiert auf hacker
abwehr
die vielzahl und dynamik der angriffe
gegen regierung und unternehmen zeigt
sehr deutlich dass es nahezu jeden
wirtschaftsbeteiligten heutzutage
treffen kann
opfer von cyber angriffen zu werden
insofern ist es heutzutage nicht mehr
die frage ob sondern wann ein
unternehmen opfer von cyberangriffen
wird und sie gutes dagegen aufgestellt
wird deshalb werden in dieser
trainingsanlage hackerangriffe simuliert
das nennt sich wargame kriegsspiel im
blauen raum sitzen die spezialisten die
die angriffe erkennen und abwehren
sollen im roten die hacker die versuchen
die stromversorgung lahm zu legen
sein system ist es infiziert ich glaube
dass alle unternehmen der kritischen
infrastruktur stromsektor ganz besonders
das thema sicherheit sehr ernst nehmen
und sich gut darauf vorbereiten
in der cyber range laufen permanent
livestreams weltweiter hacker angriffe
im vergangenen jahr zählte innogy 19
gezielte angriffe auf das deutsche
stromnetz innerhalb von sechs monaten
die teilnehmer lernen hier wie sie
solche attacken abwehren können
allerdings der hundertprozentige
sicherheit wird es aber sicher als thema
nicht geben was blüht uns bei einem lang
andauernden großflächigen stromausfall
wir sind beim bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
bbk ursula fuchs arbeitet für die
bundesbehörde seit ihrer gründung 2004
sie kennt die folgen eines stromausfalls
aus krisen übungen komplexen strom
abhängigen welt leben wird sich das auf
ganz viele bereiche auswirken
der kühlschrank die eistruhe schaltet
sich ab auch alle anderen elektrischen
haushaltsgeräte sind dann tot aber noch
brisanter wasser ohne strom versorgen
irgendwann die pumpanlage es kommt
nichts mehr aus dem hahn auch draußen
funktioniert dann nichts mehr ampeln
fallen aus tankstellen schließen genauso
supermärkte die infrastruktur bricht
zusammen
jetzt rede ich mit dem leiter der kölner
feuerwehr
sie leiten die feuerwehr vor eine
millionenstadt wie köln was machen sie
wenn die infrastruktur völlig
zusammenbricht
ja also eine millionenstadt wie köln die
hat natürlich vielfältige gefahren also
köln an sich hat eine der höchsten
risikoklasse wir haben ein europäisches
chemiedreieck und konsum werden
verkehrsknotenpunkt bundeswasserstraßen
mit einem enormen güterverkehr und wenn
teile oder möglicherweise auch die ganze
infrastruktur zusammenbricht dann
startet das städtische krisen management
also wir starten dann mit den ersten
einsatzkräften die sofort loslegen und
bauen dann durchquert ich dann eine
komplette krisen struktur auf und das
passiert alles hier unten wird das je
gemanagt in dem raum den wir da gesehen
genau hinter uns ist die leitstelle der
feuerwehr köln
hier laufen pro jahr ungefähr 400.000
notrufe auf und das wäre auch der erste
punkt wo auch eine krise beginnt nämlich
mit notruf und der wird hier bearbeitet
aber es gibt ja notrufe die sind ganz
klein aber es ging ja auch den knall den
ganz großen knall tor sind wir da
vorbereitet auf einen chemieunfall auf
cyberangriffe können sie das auch
managen und wenn ja wie beruhigen sie
die kölner also die kölnerinnen und
kölner sind bei uns im guten
das kann ich schon mal sagen ja wir
gehen wir davor also natürlich es kommt
notruf reihen der berichtet von der
notlage
wir schicken die erste einsatzkräfte
raus sind also innerhalb von 75 minuten
vor ort klären die lage
und wenn es schon eine anfangs
indikation von der katastrophen artigen
situation ist wir reden hier von einer
großschadenslage dann fahren wir
natürlich innerhalb von wenigen minuten
auch hier die krisen strukturen hoch das
sehen sie auf der anderen seite hinter
mir den stab einsatzleitung und der
koordiniert dann quasi für das ganze
stadtgebiet köln die krisenmaßnahmen wie
wird denn in dem absoluten
katastrophenfall die bevölkerung
informiert ja es ist ganz wichtig schon
eine frühe phase informationen über
verhaltensweisen und gefahrenlagen an
die bevölkerung zu geben und das machen
wir über verschiedene kanäle natürlich
ist radio nach wie vor ein medium aber
wir nutzen auch apps wie zb sap oder cut
war um dort erste informationen zu geben
mein vater ist 80 der hat weder eine app
noch kennt er alle ihrer
kommunikationswege und wenn sein strom
ausfällt hatte auch keine radio wir
haben dann noch sirenen die wir hier
aktivieren weil wir hier eben in einem
in einem hochverdichteten millionenstadt
natürlich vielfältige risiken haben als
wir können über sirene noch weckrufe
senden möglicherweise gibt es hier dann
noch ein radio das dann nutzbar ist wenn
alle stricke reißen haben wir auch noch
fahrzeuge die wir dann über lautsprecher
durch straßen schicken so dass also auf
verschiedenen kanälen sichergestellt ist
dass informationen auch den empfänger
erreichen können weil der pandemie hat
man uns alle irgendwie auf dem falschen
fuß erwischt katastrophen kündigen sich
ja nicht an sie kommen ja plötzlich was
haben wir da falsch gemacht und er
falsch gemacht würde ich nicht sagen wir
sind in der situation gewesen wohnen wo
er informationen aus china hatten auch
wir waren über video konferenz mit
peking zum beispiel in kontakt und so
ein stück weit wussten wir was in china
abgelaufen ist was wir natürlich ein
stück weit vielleicht unterschätzt haben
war das durch die globale mobilität sehr
schnell dieser wird es auch bei uns
ankommt also wir feuerwehr städtisches
krisen-management wir haben dann relativ
schnell das heißt anfang februar schon
unsere kostenstrukturen hochgefahren
aber was uns an der stelle weil sie
sagten was hat was haben wir falsch
gemacht was uns sehr kalt erwischt hat
war dass die globalen lieferketten auch
zusammengebrochen sind das heißt
notwendiges material medikamente usw
da sind wir relativ schnell in echte
versorgungskrise angelaufen und das hat
unsere leute also sehr stark beschäftigt
wie sind sie technisch ausgerüstet
manchmal mangels ja auch ein autos die
plötzlich nicht losfahren oder sind sie
da immer und ab also ich würde sagen wir
sind da sehr gut aufgestellt und zwar
bei einer bei einem großschadensereignis
ist ja so muss ein eskalationsstufen
denken und wenn wir das tun dann haben
wir die unser erster einsatzkräfte die
von der berufsfeuerwehr der freiwilligen
feuerwehr innerhalb von minuten zu
greifen
dann haben wir natürlich das problem der
durchhaltefähigkeit das heißt wir holen
uns aus dem überörtlichen kontext dann
einsatzkräfte hinzu das wird über die
bezirksregierungen über die
landesregierung koordiniert so dass wir
dann unterstützung bekommen aus
umliegenden feuerwehren auch das
bundesinnenministerium mit dem thw
unterstützt uns und wir haben natürlich
über die strukturen der bundeswehr auch
noch zugriff auf die katastrophenhilfe
das heißt wenn manpower gebrauchtes
spezial equipment dann können wir auch
auf die bundeswehr zu greifen eine
letzte frage
starkregen durch klimawandel und
wetterextreme wie ist da köln
aufgestellt ja also dass uns gerade ein
laufendes thema wir hatten ja schon
starkregen u-bahnhöfe zum beispiel stark
betroffen waren und wir sind eine
interdisziplinäre arbeitsgruppe die also
dafür maßnahmen sowohl passive maßnahmen
präventive maßnahmen auch reaktive
maßnahme arbeitet das ist aktuell würden
wir die lage reaktiv bearbeiten und
zukünftig wer wisse also im verbund von
präventiv und reaktiven maßen also sie
lassen sich von starkregen nicht
überraschen nein vielen dank für das
gespräch
es gibt aber gemeinden die haben sich
überraschen lassen gerade in sachen
starb regen münster 2014 leipzig 2015
simbach 2016 berlin 2017 für experten
steht inzwischen fest der klimawandel
ist angekommen mitten in deutschland
plötzlich riesige regenmengen starkregen
städte und gemeinden saufen ab
bisher gingen meteorologen davon aus
dass das jahrhundert ereignisse sind
extrem aber auch extrem selten
doch hier in wachtberg bei bonn haben
sie erfahren dass das nicht mehr stimmt
drei jahrhundert fluten hatten sie hier
in nur sechs jahren dreimal wurde gabi
peters modeladen komplett überflutet
ich wusste von meinem vater das
irgendwann 1930 1933 schon mal so ein
jahrhunderthochwasser war war für uns
ganz unvorstellbar und 2010 war für uns
dann halt eben auch es ist einmal und
kommt nicht wieder
aber es ist leider wieder gekommen
vorwarnzeit fast null
der starkregen überflutet den laden in
minuten
wir haben im laden gestanden hoch gebaut
und das wasser kamen also war dann
sowieso kopfhöhe die ware möbeljahr
boden alles natürlich kaputt vollgesogen
auch der wachtberger michael risch
erinnert sich mit schrecken an die guten
so sei es 2010 vor seinem haus aus man
rechnet ja nicht so etwas in der hütte
war alles weg möbel alles die türen
alles weg vor den beiden nächsten
sturzfluten aber hätte sein haus
geschützt werden können meint er
an der zu kleinen brücke habe sich das
wasser aufgestaut
schon 2010 habe er die gemeinde
aufgefordert eine größere brücke zu
bauen
da hat die gemeinde gar nichts mehr
machen weil die gemeinde gesagt hat wir
sind jahrhunderthochwasser das kommt nur
alle hundert jahre vor alle 300 jahre
er ist nach der dritten sturzflut wurde
die brücke deutlich vergrößert hat die
gemeinde den weckruf 2010 nicht ernst
genug genommen verwaltungschef
klostermann gibt zu man wird mit jeder
sturzflut besser schlagkräftiger man
kann mehr agieren mehr reagieren und
manchmal bedarf es sicherlich auch diese
ereignisse um an einem strang zu ziehen
zwischen dann wenn wachtberg hat seine
lektion inzwischen schmerzvoll gelernt
doch es kann alle gemeinden treffen weiß
oliver buchholz
er hat sich mit dem phänomen der
sturzfluten auseinandergesetzt
von einer sturzflut kann jeder betroffen
sein
dafür muss man nicht an einem gewässer
wohnen an einem bach oder an einem fluss
das wasser fließt die hänge herunter und
selbst wenn ich am berg wohnen kann das
wasser mir hinten ins gebäude reihen
laufen
nur 40 prozent aller hausbesitzer sind
gegen solche elemente schäden versichert
und die schadenssummen durch starkregen
haben sich in den letzten 30 jahren
verdreifacht auf knapp zwei milliarden
euro jährlich
wie gut sind die 11.000 gemeinden in
deutschland auf starkregen vorbereitet
wolfram geiger vom bundesamt für den
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
hat das untersucht er kommt zu dem
ergebnis
zum einen haben sich die meisten
gemeinden bislang noch nicht mit diesem
thema beschäftigt und um ein genaues
risiko zu ermitteln sind zunächst mal
die anfertigung von risiko
gefahrenkarten zwingend erforderlich mit
solchen starkregen risiko karten kann
man die katastrophe digital simulieren
ohne dass tatsächlich schäden entstehen
andreas mann erstellt seit 15 jahren
solche karten und weiß wie gemeinden
vorsorgen
es gibt einzelne gemeinden gut
vorbereitet sind aber in der summe ist
das wird sicher weniger als ein prozent
die schon wirklich taten haben und in
diesem prozess drin sind oder den schon
abgeschlossen haben also ohne risiko
karten ohne risiko analyse ohne risiko
bewertung kann eine kommune aus sicht
unserer behörde keine vernünftige
gefahrenabwehr planung durchführen die
vorsorge vorgefahren grundsätzlich
gehört zur daseinsvorsorge
selbstverständlich dazu wenn eine
gemeinde sich auf solche ereignisse
überhaupt nicht vorbereitet würde ich
das in der tat als grob fahrlässig
bezeichnen wir haben eben gesehen dass
viele städte und gemeinden auf
starkregen nicht vorbereitet waren wird
der klimawandel ignoriert in vielen
teilen der bevölkerung wird auch heute
noch der klimawandel nicht wirklich
wahrgenommen er gehört ja auch zu den
sogenannten schleichen den ereignissen
oder wenn sie so wollen kann es ja auch
zu katastrophen kommen durch den
klimawandel
und das ist unsere aufgabe auch in der
wissenschaft hier bewusstsein zu
schaffen dass diese gefahren da sind
dass sie bereits jetzt spürbar sind
gerade wenn man einen sturzfluten
beispielsweise denkt leben hier auf
einem unruhigen planeten
selbstverständlich da gibt es nur eine
antwort ja und das gerät in
vergessenheit wenn über bestimmte jahre
hinweg ruhe einkehrt also so ruhig da
rein fliegen könnte zur gefahr werden ja
selbstverständlich wir müssen einfach in
die zeit reinschauen in der
vergangenheit und dann werden wir lernen
dass der rhein auch in zukunft immer
wieder hochwasser mit sich führt wir
hatten 1995 14.000 kubikmeter pro
sekunde an uns vorbei fließen heute hat
der rhein in etwa 1200 kubikmeter pro
sekunde oder wenn wir an das gegenteil
denken ein niedrigwasser dann fließen
hier nur noch 500 kubikmeter pro sekunde
vorbei und ein schifffahrt ist nicht
mehr zu denken das kann zu
versorgungsengpässen führen
also es gibt eine vielzahl von gefahren
die wir im auge behalten müssen aber wir
können nicht voraussagen teilweise jahr
teilweise hinein denken sie an erdbeben
die sind bis zum heutigen tag und über
jahrzehnte hinweg werden die nicht
vorhersehbar seien
wir operieren hier mit
wahrscheinlichkeiten hochwasser hingegen
haben wir sehr gut im griff es gibt
wetterradar es gibt pegelstände die tage
teilweise sogar wochen vorher bestimmte
warnsignale geben können und wir können
hier rechtzeitig reagieren und sind auch
gerade in dieser region bonn köln sehr
gut aufgestellt mit dem hochwasser
kompetenzzentrum beispielsweise also für
naturkatastrophen sind wir gut
aufgestellt oder brauchen wir da auch
neue konzepte nicht generell noch mal es
gibt eine vielzahl von gefahren typen
die zu katastrophen führen können und
wir müssen sehr genau hinschauen welche
typ von natur gefahr für zu welcher
möglichen katastrophe also denken sie
einfach an meteorologische ereignisse
oder an die pandemie die wir gegenwärtig
haben oder an geologischen morphologisch
ereignisse wie erdbeben also es kommt
ganz auf den typ auf die charakteristika
das gefahr der gefahr ein sichern um
hier vorsorge maßnahmen konkret treffen
zu können gibt es in deutschland oder
europa region wo es besonders gefährlich
ist ja selbstverständlich denken wir
beispielsweise an gebirgsregion allein
durch das relief bedingt haben wir dort
unheimliche zur verfügung stehende
energie wenn sie so wollen
und gerade in diesem kontext ist der
klimawandel entscheidend hier kommt es
zu sogenannten zeitverzögerten effekten
der klimawandel wirkt ja nicht nur eine
erhöhung der temperatur in der luft
sondern auch im festgestein und das
bewirkt wiederum veränderungen denken
sie an einen gefrorenen fels wir
sprechen hier auch von permafrost wenn
er über mehrere jahre hinweg gefroren
ist und genau das finden wir im
alpenraum und das beginnt aufzutauen
dann drohen uns große felsstürze die
sehr plötzlich alpentäler und auch vor
länder betreffen können und zu
katastrophalen schäden oder katastrophen
führen können was ist mit der selbst
vorsorge wie kann ich oder sie auch uns
auf eventualitäten einstellen
nun das kann natürlich jeder auch im
kleinen beginnen eine gewisse vorsorge
zu treffen falls es einen
versorgungsengpass gibt beispielsweise
wasser zu bevorraten 20 liter pro person
für zehn tage empfiehlt das bbk aber das
allein genügt nicht ich glaube wir
müssen hier auch eine neue kultur des
denkens propagieren damit bereits im
kindesalter
gelernt wird dass wir auf einem
unruhigen planeten leben und wir
gerüstet sind besser vorbereitet sind
und das ist ja auch das ziel der
forschung hier in der vorsorge in der
katastrophenvorsorge in der prävention
besser zu werden
prävention ist das stichwort wie war
deutschland direkt nach dem weltkrieg
1945 in sachen katastrophenschutz
aufgestellt die autobahn a4 östlich von
boxen
was wenig bekannt ist bis anfang der
90er jahre war diese strecke für den
verkehr weitgehend gesperrt
wolfgang zimmermann hat hier als
autobahnmeister gearbeitet schauen die
es 1990 kam es in betrieb gewesen
sondern auf diesen stillgelegt
autobahnabschnitt zwischen bautzen ost
und weißenberg befanden sich 66 hallen
in den hallen ist getreide eingelagert
gewesen und zwar als staatsreserve er
aufnahmen von 1990 zutritt hatten nur
mitarbeiter der lagerwirtschaft eine
halle reihte sich an die nächste
das umzäunte gelände erstreckte sich
über 14 kilometer
mitte der 60er jahre hatten die ddr
behörden die errichtung der 66 hallen
auf der autobahn angeordnet mit der
begründung die strecke werde ohnehin
kaum genutzt
die hallen auf der autobahn waren
zeitweise das größte getreidelager der
ddr bis zu 300.000 tonnen konnten in den
66 speichern deponiert werden
als reserve für not und krisenfälle auch
im westen hatte man vor 1990 enorme
vorräte angelegt vor allem in west
berlin
nach dem mauerfall wurde das ganze
ausmaß bekannt für die sogenannte senats
reserve hatte man etwa vier millionen
tonnen güter eingelagert tiefgefrorene
schweinehälften zum beispiel aufgebahrt
an orten die nur wenige eingeweihte
kanten mann wollte auf alles vorbereitet
sein zb auf einer erneuten blockade
west-berlins es gab vorräte an büchsen
ananas zucker
und millionen streichholzschachtel
nach der wende beschloss der berliner
senat die auflösung der vorratslager
ihre aufnahmen von 1990 wie soldaten der
sowjetarmee lebensmittel aus den
berliner beständen auflagen etwa ein
viertel der senats reserve ging als
hilfslieferung in die sowjetunion wo
damals eine hungersnot drohte und heute
aktuell und erhält der staat nach
angaben der zuständigen bundesbehörde
150 nahrungsmittel lager verteilt auf
das gesamte bundesgebiet
in diesen hallen in sachsen anhalt etwa
werden vorräte vermutet eine bestätigung
gibt es dafür nicht
die standorte sind geheim
im falle einer versorgungskrise könnten
die lager ziel von einbrechern oder gar
plünderern werden heißt es bei den
lagerstätten handelt es sich in der
regel um private agrarunternehmen die
vom bund bezahlt werden
2018 hat die bundesanstalt für
landwirtschaft und ernährung auf youtube
dieses video veröffentlicht in dem die
bevorratung praxis erklärt wird kann
situationen geben in denen die
infrastruktur die unser tägliches leben
bestimmt nicht mehr funktioniert und in
einer solchen situation wo kein laden
der waren harz wo kein kühlschrank mehr
funktioniert ist es wichtig dass wir die
ernährung der menschen sicherstellen
archiv aufnahmen aus dem jahr 2010 von
einem vorratslager in sachsen aktueller
teilt die behörde keine
drehgenehmigungen und gibt auch keine
interviews
seit damals hat sich aber wenig geändert
die not reserven bestehen vor allem aus
weizen wie hier als kerner
der vorrat beträgt rund 600.000 tonnen
daneben sind auch linsen erbsen und reis
eingelagert alles muss regelmäßig
kontrolliert werden reichen wir das dann
über mehrere wochen
es ist ja dann im ernstfall nicht daran
gedacht da hier ein herrschaftliches mal
einzunehmen 900 geht es nur darum dass
die menschen in den betroffenen gebieten
auch satt werden der einsatz der
notvorräte sei in deutschland bisher
noch nie nötig gewesen teilte das
zuständige landesamt auf anfrage der
umschau mit auch in der aktuellen corona
krise bestehe keine notwendigkeit auf
die staatlichen reserven zurückzugreifen
doch ist die ernährungs vorsorge
wirklich effektiv organisiert fachleute
haben da zweifel
der bundesrechnungshof hat die
staatliche bevorratung praxis mehrmals
eingehend geprüft zuletzt 2009 10 in
seinem bericht stellte der rechnungshof
fest es fehle bei der ernährung vorsorge
an einem schlüssigen gesamtkonzept
teilweise würden waren vorgehalten
deren notwendigkeit zweifelhaft ist
andreas kling ist fachmann für
katastrophenschutz und lehrt an der
privaten hochschule für
humanwissenschaften in berlin
er sieht ganz praktische probleme die im
ernstfall auftreten könnten
sie müssen sich vorstellen das getreide
muss zum mehl vermahlen werten die
bäcker müssen pro debatten die brote
müssen verteilt werden und dass alles
vielleicht noch unterlagen wo wenig
strom da ist wo energie vielleicht unter
die energie versorgung unterbrochen ist
oder wo auch viele zb die mitarbeiter
der mühlen und der bäckereien krank sind
oder die lkw-fahrer nicht arbeiten
können wir das sehr schwierig es ist
besser als gar nichts es gibt ja manche
länder die gar keine vorsorge mehr
treffen aber aus logistischer sicht
gesehen ist könnte deutlich besser sein
dieser beitrag macht nachdenklich bei
der offiziellen lebensmittelversorgung
im krisenfall scheint vieles im argen zu
liegen
deshalb hat auch das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
in dieser broschüre einen privaten grund
vorrat empfohlen für zehn tage und für
eine person
und der sieht so aus 20 liter wasser
brauchen wir 3,5 kilogramm getreide
produkte kartoffeln nudeln reis vier
kilogramm gemüse und hülsenfrüchte die
natürlich in dosen oder glas dann 25
kilogramm obst in dosen oder glas das
ist ja haltbar und müsse dann drei liter
haltbare milch 15 kilogramm fisch und
fleisch außerdem öl mehl zucker kekse
zwieback und salzstangen und damit man
nicht zehn tage lang nudeln mit
tomatensoße essen muss gibt es auch
einen notfall kochbuch wenn das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe einen notfall kochbuch
plant steigt angst auf droht der totale
stromausfall ganz deutschland in tiefer
dunkelheit jeder einzelne von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten
wissen sie etwas was wir nicht wissen
was wir uns sorgen machen
nein sie müssen sich keine sorgen machen
die veranstaltung hier hat nicht zum
hintergrund dass es irgendeinen grund
gibt für panik sondern ganz im gegenteil
wir wollen haben dass die menschen in
deutschland alle bürgerinnen und bürger
ein notvorrat anlegen wie man diesen
notvorrat auch ohne strom lecker
zubereitet soll bald das notfall
kochbuch verraten die idee dafür hatten
die bonner hilfsorganisationen und das
geplante kochbuch ist er ein sinnbild
für das große ganze
wir möchten den impuls geben wird uns im
notfall kochbuch sich gedanken zu machen
wie ich selber bin ich mit auf die
katastrophe vorbereitet was machen die
folgen mit mir und auch das kochbuch so
alltagstauglich gestalten dass man das
auch gerne außerhalb der katastrophe aus
dem regal nimmt und damit auch koch
innerhalb der katastrophe ist ein
trinkwasser vorrat ein guter plan
außerdem raten die katastrophenhelfer zu
hamsterkäufen denn kochen ohne strom ist
möglich ohne lebensmittel er nicht
vorreiter für zehn tage empfehlen
hilfsorganisationen und zeigen wie man
lebensmittel ohne strom zubereitet
mandeln zerkleinern ohne mixa kann man
etwa mit einem nudelholz oder einfach
mit einem messer aber wenn wirklich der
strom ausfällt es dann unsere größte
sorge dass es kein warmes essen gibt er
dass der kühlschrank ausfällt würde ich
sagen ja handys du vielleicht irgendwann
auch was mir fehlen würde wäre
sicherlich irgendwann morgens die warme
dusche
wär doch was warmes essen will braucht
nicht nur das passende kochbuch was ist
denn jetzt das wichtigste was sich als
utensil brauche wenn ich ohne strom
kochen will könnte sogar wichtiger sein
als das kochbuch ja ohne strom könnte
auch eine taschenlampe helfen ein paar
kerzen und die streichhölzer ob sie sich
diesen vorhat anschaffen das bleibt
jedem selbst überlassen
aber die aktuelle pandemie hat gezeigt
dass es zwar nicht an lebensmitteln
fehlt aber an schutz material und da
haben die menschen auch selbst
vorgesorgt indem sie schutzmasken genäht
haben
das war schon unser themenschwerpunkt
vielen dank fürs zuschauen
tschüss
[Musik]